ich begrüße jetzt im studio einen ganz
besonderen gast daniel negroni kennen
wir aus dsds aus dem dschungelcamp
die zuschauer kennen kennen dich
natürlich und wir wollen nachher auch
sprechen über das thema ja die not der
künstler wie sieht es aus mit augen
ritten wie geht es in der branche weiter
aber wir kommen zunächst zum thema reise
ärger hast du reise ärger gehabt sind
mir auch gefallen not ja ich habe er
gehabt gehabt in dem seine junge sein
abschied ich hatte ein junge sein
abschied gebot von meinem großen bruder
noch kurz sind und das ist dann aufgrund
von corona komplett flach gefallen
und ja da haben wir auch ewigkeiten
gekämpft um jetzt haben wir wenigstens
im nachhinein eine entschädigung bekommt
und das ganze findet jetzt nächstes jahr
statt ach so immerhin das ging gut aus
als gegen anschluss noch gut aus daniela
also wirklich toll dass das bin ich sehr
froh drüber ja noch nicht so gut da
brauchen sie gar nicht mal unbedingt
unsere hilfe in hinflug schön und gut
aber ohne unterkunft und rücken kriegt
man das natürlich auch nicht absolut das
verstehen wir durchaus aber auf jeden
fall ist der urlaub erst mal passé
das ist natürlich wirklich sehr nervig
ich frage auch ein studiogast daniele
kannst du verstehen da ärgert man sich
doch wirklich schwarz darüber oder na ja
absolut also ich glaube wenn man eine
urlaubsreise gebucht hat vor allem halt
auch für familie und sodann ist ja auch
die kinder sind vor vorfreude glaub ich
kaum zu bremsen und wenn dann halt so
was passiert dann sollte man schon wie
jetzt auch eben gerade schon erwähnt man
so kulant sein und sagen okay man kriegt
das geld zurück oder man kriegt einen
anderen flug erstattet sowie das eben
bei mir war da hatte ich halt einfach
glück und ja also ich kann mich da schon
in die lage hineinversetzen glaube schon
dass das ziemlich ärgerlich ist du bist
hier weil wir über ein ganz bestimmtes
thema sprechen wollen die not der
künstler also wir hatten schon viele
künstler gestern war es zum beispiel
bernhard brink in einer sendung die
machen sich natürlich große sorgen um
die zukunft die können zur zeit nicht
auftreten oder nur in wirklich sehr sehr
ganz kleinen rahmen
wie ist die lage mit den auftritten bei
dir na ja also ich hab natürlich in
anführungsstrichen noch das glück dass
ich eben nicht hunderttausende von
hallen fülle sondern dass es bei mir
halt eher um den club shows geht und das
ganze und vor allem bei uns künstlern
bei den kleineren künstlern sind die
klubs haushalt eben das
überlebenswichtige und die haben halt
leider alle momentan zu ich kann man an
einer hand abzählen wie auf wie vielen
bühnen nicht in diesem jahr stand und
man macht sich natürlich gedanken weil
ich meine
man hat für viele ist geplant in diesem
jahr viele songs geplant die vielleicht
auch veröffentlicht werden hätten sollen
was alles nicht passieren konnte weil
halt eben man gebremst wurde von einer
sache die man meines erachtens nach
bestimmt auch anders in den griff
bekommen hätte und ich sehe das halt vor
allem als beispiel schweiz vor ein paar
tagen war um ein bisschen abzuschalten
weil ich mal am see und da habe ich mich
dann gewundert warum am see tausende von
menschen sein dürfen aber so ein klub
abends nicht auf haben darf dass wir
halt als künstler da mal wieder auf der
bühne stehen können und so ein bisschen
geld verdienen können und ganz ehrlich
da bringt uns auch diese soforthilfe
dies dann da gab nichts dann muss ich
leider art sein weil das bringt mich
zwei monate über die runden und dann ist
die sache wieder durch aber was kommt
danach und ich weiß halt und das sieht
man halt auch jetzt noch dass diese
klubs und alles was gerade so passiert
einfach nicht aufmacht und da gibt es
auch irgendwie keinen plan habe ich das
gefühl da ist nicht irgendwie so ein
ding wo man sagt okay wir haben da einen
gewissen weg wie wir das ganze wieder
ans laufen bringen wollen sondern als
wären wir vergessen habe ich so langsam
muss dafür ja gut überall da geht es
jetzt hier wirklich um 250.000 euro das
projekt irgendwann darüber nachdenken
dass man dann wenn ich das höre dass man
dann ein schreiben zurück geschickt
bekommen das öffnet und das wieder
zugeklebt quasi und sagt so kommen
zurück an den absender
das finde ich schon echt sehr respektlos
ich habe herrn denn so gefragt wann geht
es weiter was glaubst du wann werden die
hallen wieder größer herbst oder wird
erst im nächsten jahr wie lange hältst
du das auch finanziell noch durch
finanziell ich würde behaupten maximal
noch bis zum dritten vierten monat
nächstes jahr dann wird es sehr eng an
sondern weil ich hab mir gesagt ich habe
fixkosten die muss ich denken jeden
monat und wenn halt am monatsende nicht
reinkommt dann ist es schon hart wie
gesagt ich bin jetzt dabei zu überlegen
ob ich halt parallel doch noch anfange
mini job zu machen um einfach nur zu
wissen da kommt noch ein bisschen geld
am ende des monats das wäre das dann
selbst wenn es ein kellner ist dann ist
es so jeder job ist ein job und du
würdest wieder kellnern ich würde das
machen ja einfach nur zu wissen dass
sich zumindest am ende des monats selbst
wissen und 450 euro job ist 150 euro
sind 54 euro und ganz ehrlich gerade
momentan liegt halten künstler jeden
penny auf die goldwaage und deswegen
also ich würde auch gern mal ganz
ehrlich
deutliche worte also ich hoffe dass es
natürlich nicht dazu kommt sondern dass
die massen wieder kommen und dass du
auch wieder sein auftreten kann es
vielleicht auch abseits von
hochzeit feiern obwohl die bestimmt sehr
schön werden mit dir privat habe ich so
gut da wünsche ich dir alles gute dass
wieder geld in die kasse kommt vielen
dank dass du hier willkommen zu unserer
neuen rubrik nämlich bild kämpft für sie